yeah I'll tell Beyonce if you see her to
stop biting all my stuff she'd be
stealing all my ideas and everything my
fashion my fashion Beyonce most this
dress but I'd say she she she stole my
dress idea this is this is the way I
dress Beyonce get yourself together
we're sorry apparently he was taking
some sort of stimulant we're having some
fun keep it down I wanna know if he's
organ donor count it again I ain't ready
counted again stealing is we laugh up
hello hello this is my dear thank you
all for coming today for the reading of
the wheel brought to you by everybody
who died and Fandango I'm still alive
end up in this happened to me and I'm
running from Tyler Perry he's trying to
kill me and I'm currently out on the
road with Madeira fairway Archer
Tyler Perry ham yea yea though she
walked in the ballet with the shadow lab
Little Red Riding Hood in the three
bears she feared no evil cuz the Three
Little Pigs was not around any
hallelujah okay listen I'm going to give
the reading of the wheel so y'all will
know that this is official this is the
reading of the wheel to my best friends
out there I'm gonna leave my bras I
haven't worn it since 1972 sorry a few
cups smaller but y'all can make ups pair
of shoes for your children or something
and to all the ladies out there I'm
gonna leave my black dongs be careful
with your kids to make sure they don't
put them on they face cuz he looks like
a what kind of mask but don't that's a
whole nother story
okay and
lastly to Joe I am leaving absolutely
nothing you were my worst nightmare
living with me all those years I don't
believe in divorce
I believe in death do you part so you
got to die even though you my brother
how you don't me I'm okay
well you looks bad we here cuz your
daddy's dead not me coordinating the
funeral I hope y'all can appreciate what
I'm gonna try to do and if you need
anything just let us know I've noticed
about funerals I don't bear it a lot of
men a lot of them every little villain
be mr. Matthias family funeral is in
theaters on March 1st you can get your
tickets at Fandango and you could go out
and see man Diaz family future oh that's
what I'm talking about I'm talking about
the filter Chantal Chantal okay I'm
talking about the funeral
the funeral is all coming out March 1st
it's a funny movie and I am it stars me
and in me and I also get starring me all
of us in what is it ok get surprised oh
we want to give away some prizes to all
the people who is watching live on
Facebook and banner turned me a letter
this is uh I could do better oh this one
was old it was good I was I was so good
in this one
Obama did I remember I was I was really
good and this taraji was just oh and my
dear Fallon futuro
Debbie Debbie look fair the future are
Madea Madea you can win these prizes
they all star me hey listen
oh this is my favorite one my dear goes
to jail in Vice
you got to see this it's really good oh
boo - ok look oh this the boot this this
was the funny booth the second bullet
thank y'all for making their number one
but the first one fact this was funny
this was so funny sorry
they just separate sometime I gotta get
something to hold them together I should
get Oprah things don't stay up like they
used to but listen I'm gonna tell all of
y'all something out there on the
Instagram
be careful meeting people on insta
Everett be careful meeting people on
Instagram yeah I'm staying
yeah but I'm a sign one of these to you
y'all gotta be careful me no people on
Instagram car people don't look like
they look on in square go to my
Instagram page you see but I really look
like cuz this is this is our is the
filter to make me look this
[Music]
okay so men day there what I'm a sign
one for Mende Mende and I'm gonna make
sure you get this men and what I'm us I
am one of these planes
what are these lovely posters for you
and rich and thank you sir mash okay
Facebook live
but listen be cowboy in spare cuz I was
dating this man on Instagram
and he told me he lived in a gated
community he was in prison okay Erica
how you doing Erica thank you so much
for for all of your love and support all
of these years yes I'm currently on tour
we are in Los Angeles we have been sold
out for to to determine days we started
to Oakland California and we sold out of
that we catch for you then we went to a
Phoenix Arizona turn that's the best
barbecue I ever had little J's Little
Miss J that's the best barbecue in
Phoenix y'all got some good barbecue but
waiting there there my fire on half your
own for that you need to give me some
day of celebrity treat but next time I
ain't coming back but that's a good damn
barbecue right there Shirley Shirley is
that Shirley Caesar is that shirt oh
another shirt how you doing sure too
baby
Shirley I made one for you that's for
Shirley maybe why he smiling y'all put
the smile on his face he seemed like he
was a happy man in his final moments
it's stuck we're sorry
mm-hmm apparently he was taking some
sort of stimulant this is a good movie
there I'm gonna try to go see on March
the first day listen to me yeah I'll be
working on my day I'm nursing around
home only damn if never flicker listen
go out go out to the movie theater get
out have some fun and move and live get
out there have some fun it the mood take
some back to the mood to see my dear
to the future oh but the offense
reinsurer would be in the movie to you
oh it's back there - its back there to
see my dear fancy future will be in the
theatres on March the 1st so please go
out and see it here what are we going to
do we are going to give away some
tickets back to you in the studio
Anderson Cooper oh he ain't there's just
me y'all want me to do the whole damn
thing by myself hey you should've got
brown or somebody in here um yes we're
going to give away some tickets on
Fandango if you want to buy tickets let
me give you a chantell's email address
her email address is shot no culture but
y'all can email me on instagram at my
dears Instagram yes I've been trying to
work Instagram now by myself and it's
been it's a lot of fun I just started I
only have um a few files worse but y'all
come come on I'm opposed to more
pictures of myself and I know how to get
my followers up oh like I do is pose do
a couple of nudes and that's all I got
if I do a couple of news my father's go
through the roof but see I'm not the
kind of lady the more I was stripping
back in the day them days it's gone gone
for me okay and um but i but i but I'll
try I might have just do a little top
list one just let's not just about right
here just to give you our little
cleavage but it went back in the day you
know Jordan back in the dating table
used to happen I was a stripper and my
favorite song I strip to was a gospel
song yes it's called ah write it my pony
and see people say they ain't no gosh no
that is didn't Jesus ride a pony into
Bethlehem but ask somebody really listen
to the lyrics okay we're gonna give away
some tickets on Fandango hello welcome
to my dear Elif here open March first
add to the movie theater near you you
can get your tickets at Fandango I'm
pulling over what
I thought I'd be strip club
so you know I know how to do sexy
fandango gonna make me it's a lascivious
Fandango Fandango gonna help me our
paper commercially gonna give me a lot
of money to do commercial for therefore
all the movies they I just did a deal
with Fandango for ten million dollars
they just they just approved it they
just approved a ten million dollar deal
for me
y'all put that in The Hollywood Reporter
and the trays and everything the whole
contract is here right now I'm actually
gonna sign it right now so that you know
that I this is real and I just signed
the contract that I'm waiting on the
check that I'm do playing so anyway joy
listen them I will try to glass seat my
dear family country it is in the move
did on March first
don't buy a bootleg bootleg get you be
there if I catch you thank you so much
[Music]
oh you told me huh don't be whispering
up an issue I would get better give you
some is this really my last my dear
movie well the truth is Tyler Perry and
I have been having issues for a long
time and I don't like to be negative but
I don't like his ass I never have he's
just been so mean to be and he don't
treat me right he don't treat me right
at all and see now he got all these new
people in this movie and then he like
see the way he treated by all the Davis
and Karen Washington and our taraji with
all them word for he don't treat me like
that
see I don't get no Cadillacs and all
that so he make me drive my own product
and it's at I don't want to work with
him to mow so I'm looking for a new
partner to work with yes I'm thinking
about doing a movie with Bradley Cooper
it's a star is born again that's what we
think about doing I'm gonna take Lady
Gaga's place yes it's not gonna be later
the guy's gonna be brand new Cooper let
my dick attire and we're gonna do it
we're gonna do the movie together city
you want to know if I'm running for
president yes I'm running for president
me and Camilla Harris and I warrant
warrant diet and what the warrant Lisbon
warrant and are and also of Joe Biden we
all on the same ticket I am going to be
the Secretary of Defense although I
wanted to be the treasurer but they
don't trust me with the money what is my
favorite material my favorite Madhu
is really simple cause people ask me
this question all the time what is my
favorite Madea movie my favorite Madeira
is every movie Madea is in I mean I just
love everything I do I
I love me okay I'll look you for my
birthday
you ain't got to give me no give you
ain't got to buy me love you ain't got
to give me the okay hell I make my own
self a cake say oh you shouldn't have
well thank you yeah that's what I do so
yes they all my favorite I love all them
I'm gonna sign this for Haley Haley
ain't that Justin Bieber wife name I
wonder who's here there Haley Bieber we
just begin to wrap up they're telling me
it's time to wrap up and I just want you
all to know that it's been wonderful
spending this afternoon with you you
know your ass at work and you supposed
to be working please get back to work
and I will see you in the future
on March 1st if you're not coming to see
the play my dear family what one other
Madea Madea is on the tour right now and
and yes and yes thank you all so much
for watching and please look forward on
my Instagram to my feature coming nudes
[Music]